une autre entreprise qui elle cherche à
s'agrandir ses sectroniques spécialisés
dans la fabrication de cartes
électroniques en particulier dans le
domaine ferroviaire c'est en industrie
basée à Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine a vu
son chiffre d'affaires doublé en 8 ans
le carnet de commande est plein pour
2023 aujourd'hui elle veut donc agrandir
ses locaux et embaucher une bonne santé
économique qui est tout de même freinée
depuis peu par la pénurie de semis
conducteurs reportage de Romain Delville
dans les ateliers de sectroniques à
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine il n'y a pas
que les machines qui produisent des
cartes électroniques la conception est
aussi manuelle qu'il s'agisse de soudure
de précision de lier les câbles avec
municip ou le montage d'un portique par
exemple
l'entreprise qui a aussi un bureau
d'études à Saint-Avertin cultivent son
lien privilégié avec le ferroviaire 45%
de ses commandes est diversifient ses
clients nucléaires photovoltaïques
matériel médical 750
000 pièces sont sorties des ateliers en
2022 et s'il y a un frein au
développement immédiat c'est que les
semi-conducteurs qui viennent de Taïwan
sont au coeur d'un conflit commercial et
géopolitique entre la Chine et les
États-Unis parfois on est bloqué par des
protectionnistes entre États entre
continents qui nous empêche de recevoir
la pièce il y a des produits que j'ai
attendu depuis de 18 mois avant de les
réceptionner et donc ça bloquait bien
entendu la planification des projets et
également la livraison des pièces et
lorsqu'on est on doit livrer la SNCF
Alstom EDF pour les centrales c'est
compliqué de leur faire comprendre que
on va avoir 6 mois de retard alors que
ils ont un des programmes qui sont bien
validés en 8 ans le chiffre d'affaires a
doublé pour atteindre 11 millions et
demi d'euros l'entreprise est soutenue
par les dispositifs France relance
territoire d'industrie et au niveau
régional l'Agence de développement
économique verse une aide de 500.000
euros sur un investissement total de 2
millions et demi pour l'agrandissement
et la modernisation du site de
production qui passera d'ici 18 mois de
2100 à 3000 m². autre sujet c'est
l'emploi nous sommes sur des secteurs
qui sont porteurs d'emploi avec à la
fois le renouvellement des générations
mais aussi l'augmentation des effectifs
et donc c'est aussi pour nous très
important être auprès des entreprises
pour voir sur quel secteur de formation
il faut aller il faut aller par
l'apprentissage il faut aller par de
lycée professionnel on en parle par la
période il faut aller par nos écoles
d'ingénieurs nos universités 48 ans
après sa création sectronics se prépare
à une nouvelle jeunesse derrière
l'agrandissement et la volonté rapide
d'un chiffre d'affaires de 14 millions
l'entreprise espère passer de 70
permanents à 90 d'ici deux ans